merci la parole est à thierry mariani
merci madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre du
budget payer pour une prestation
monsieur le ministre dans notre temps
dont on est exclu
voilà ce que votre majorité a adopté en
juillet 2012 en mettant en place un
dispositif visant à assujettir les non
résidents à des prélèvements sociaux sur
les revenus fonciers et si on les plus
values immobilières perçu en france
l'opposition à l'époque avait dénoncé
cette mesure qui est non seulement
injuste mais injustifié puisque elle
prend les français expatriés comme
cibles depuis nous l'avons combattu et
depuis la justice européenne nous a
donné raison le verdict vous le savez
sans appel condamné par la cour de
justice de l'union européenne est
condamné par le conseil d'état or le 24
septembre dernier lors de la
présentation du projet de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 2016 vous avez
annoncé vouloir affecter désormais ces
prélèvements au financement de
prestations non contributives identiques
à celles financées par les autres impôts
bref alors que vous êtes condamné vous
nous faites un tour de bonneteau pour
pouvoir conserver cette imposition par
une pirouette fiscale scandaleuse vous
comptez donc faire échec aux décisions
de la cour de justice de l'union
européenne et du conseil d'état
pire encore seuls les non résidents
installés au sein de l'union européenne
ou de l'espace économique européen
pourrait se faire rembourser
la question est donc simple mais triple
en clair allez vous appliquer la
décision de justice est allé vous
rembourser les contribuables qui ont
payé cette taxe quels seront les
contribuables qui rentreront dans le
champ de ce remboursement et entendez
vous sérieusement traitée différemment
les contribuables en fonction du pays où
ils se trouvent
c'est à dire en clair est-ce que si on
habite la belgique ou le luxembourg on
sera remboursé alors que si on est en
chine à singapour ou en australie et
qu'on ramène des contrats pour la france
on ne sera pas remboursé voilà monsieur
le ministre la question que les
expatriés attendent aujourd'hui
mais si la parole est à monsieur le
secrétaire d'état chargé du budget
oui madame la présidente madame
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
mariani
votre question est simple mais triple et
donc elle appelle une réponse simple et
triple sur votre première question si la
france appliquera tel le l'arrêt de la
cour de justice de l'union européenne
comment pourrait-il en être autrement
évidemment la france appliquera ce cet
arrêt l'arrêt dit de ruyter pour les
spécialistes
deuxièmement est ce que la france
remboursera les contributions qu'elle a
perdu depuis trois ans auprès d'une
certaine catégorie de contribuables en
fonction de cet arrêt la réponse est
simple et positive
bien entendu la france remboursera les
montants de ces jets de crds qu'elle a
peur qu'elle a perçues et troisième
volet de votre question est ce que la
france l'appliquera à l'ensemble des
ressortissants visé par l'arrêt oui mais
a eu seulement l'arrêt de la cour de
justice de l'union européenne concerne
non pas la question de la résidence mais
concerne la question de la filiation un
régime de sécurité sociale de l'espace
économique européen et donc l'arrêt de
la cour de justice de l'union européenne
ne vise que les ressortissants de ces
pays c'est à dire l'union européenne
plus la suisse le liechtenstein et la
norvège et est donc l'application sera
strict et intégral n'est pas question
d'aller au-delà
d'ailleurs je vous redis que le conseil
constitutionnel a toujours jugé que la
csg faisait partie des impôts de toutes
natures et effectivement nous resterons
dans le cadre de la constitution évident
merci la parole